no us web company has really cracked
China it's time they stopped trying
Google Facebook Amazon Microsoft eBay
all have either been shut out of China
or a barely treading water
the latest loser is uber which sold its
Chinese operations after it lost
billions of dollars in the country Apple
has done well but has struggled there
recently so why can't American internet
companies succeed in China three reasons
one China's web Titans are unimaginably
big and broad making it tough for
foreigners to compete with them
alibaba's ecommerce websites handle more
online sales and Amazon and eBay
combined and Baidu has a bigger share of
web searches in China than Google does
in the u.s. to China's laws and
government interventions favor local
companies for example Facebook and
Twitter are banned in China and Google
pulled out a few years ago because it
was the target of massive cyber attacks
and it didn't want to comply with
censorship rules and three Chinese
technology has become really good local
companies make smartphones as good as
iPhones but with features tailored to
Chinese tastes like guessing your age
from selfies and Chinese tech ideas are
being copied elsewhere like Facebook
turning its chat app messenger into a
version of WeChat the might of Chinese
internet superpowers their tech prowess
and government help has hardened China
into an online economy where locals rule
China seems too big to ignore but it's
also too hard to crack for America's web
powers